Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the Lang focus channel.
And my name is Paul today's topic is the Polish language
or [inaudible] as it's called in Polish.
Polish is the official language of the central European country of Poland where
97% of the population speaks it as a native language that makes Poland the
most linguistically homogenous country in Europe. It's the second,
most widely spoken Slavic language after Russian with around 45 million
native speakers and an additional 5000002nd language speakers. As you may know,
Slavic languages are a branch of the Indo-European language family between the
year 500 CE and 1000 CE prodo Slavic,
gradually diverged into dialects. And by 1000 CE,
there were already distinct West Slavic,
East Slavic and South Slavic languages and dialects of these three languages
developed into the languages of each Slavic branch.
The West Slavic languages include Polish Czech, Slovak Serbian,
a minority language in Eastern Germany.
And Kasabian a minority language in Poland.
Poland first became a state in the 10th century around the time that Slavic was
developing into various distinct languages.
The unification of various Slavic tribes within one Polish state helped tie
their dialects together as a single language,
the Christianization of Poland took place in the decades following the creation
of the Polish state.
And along with that came Latin V as a Roman Catholic church,
which became the formal written language.
And the language of the nobility Polish continued to be the predominant spoken
language among the general population,
but Latin certainly had some influence on Polish because of its prestigious
position.
Polish was not a written language until the adoption of Christianity and the
arrival of Latin from that point on macular Polish began to be written
informally using the Latin alphabet.
The oldest sample of written Polish that we know of is a list of names dating
back to the year 1136,
the oldest written Polish sentence that we know of dates back to 1270.
There are more substantial texts from the 14th century onwards.
As Polish became more commonly written from the beginnings,
the Latin alphabet was insufficient for writing all the different sounds of
Polish. So over time,
Polish writers began using a variety of diacritics that have become part of the
Polish alphabet and the characteristic part of Polish writing during the yellow
onion dynasty Polish became an official language alongside Latin.
Also during this time,
cities were founded and administered under a German system of law known as muck
divorce law due to the influence of this system of law.
Numerous German words entered Polish German,
lone words in Polish include meaning town, council and boredom,
meaning mayor also there had always been contact with Germanic speakers,
especially in the areas all the way back to prodo Slavic.
So there are other dramatic loan words in Polish that go back a long way.
Latin remained an official language alongside Polish through the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth,
but Polish had gradually become more widely used by the nobility than Latin in
the 16th century, while Polish was becoming more standardized,
it served as the vehicle for the golden age of Polish literature.
It also became the lingua franca throughout much of central and Eastern Europe
spoken by the ruling classes, not only in Lithuania,
but also in Ukraine and Belarus,
which were mostly part of the Commonwealth at the time.
The third official language of the Commonwealth was Ruthenian,
which was spoken in the Eastern areas and would later develop into Ukrainian and
bellow Russi and dialects Polish was influenced by Ruthenian to some extent,
due to contact Poland was erased from the map between seven 95
in 1918, after being partitioned between the Russian empire,
Austria and the kingdom of pressure. And later the German empire,
which it was a part of Polish ceased to be an official language anywhere.
And dialectal differences grew in the different occupied parts of Poland.
After the first world war,
the borders of Europe were redrawn and an independent Polish state was restored
lands,
which were considered historically Polish were taken back from occupying powers,
but not all lands borders were once again,
redrawn after world war two,
with the recovered territories being given from Germany to Poland and the Soviet
union occupying Eastern areas and making them part of Belarus and Ukraine,
many poles were forcibly transferred from those neighboring countries to Poland,
transferred to being a euphemism for kicked out this forced transfer of poles
from their homes to different dialect areas resulted in dialect leveling the
loss of dialectal differences and transfer. In other words,
expulsion of non poles to neighboring countries made Poland a very
linguistically homogenous country.
Today four main dialects of Polish are usually recognized,
but the differences are now slight. There's greater Polish, lesser Polish.
I'm a Soviet and Salesian.
Those speakers often consider themselves a separate language community and
sometimes counted as [inaudible],
which is generally considered a separate language,
but as closely related Polish.
So what is Polish like pronunciation and orthography Polish writer
think has a number of characteristic features that are quite striking at first
glance. The Polish alphabet has 32 letters,
but there are also seven diagraphs pairs of letters,
which represent individuals notice that four of those diagraphs feature the
letter Z. This makes sense.
See the most common letter in Polish writing and notice that there are two
additional letters that are derived from Z,
which appear in another two diagraphs. If you include those people,
seeing Polish and writing for the first time will definitely notice the
abundance of Z's and Z like letters.
But those two Z derived letters are not the only special letters in Polish.
There are nine in total. This letter is pronounced womb. While in Polish,
the letter w is normally pronounced.
These letters represent nasal vowels,
more specifically vowels followed by nasal semi vowels.
The exact quality of the nasal sound varies depending on the surrounding sounds.
And the nasal sound is normally absent before wa or in the nasal air
at the end of a word. For example,
this word is normally pronounced Cher and is only pronounced like this shell
in very careful formal speech.
There are some noticeably.
Long consonant clusters in Polish.
This one has a cluster of five continents in a row best as Glendening,
meaning ruthless. Then there's this one [inaudible] meaning crime.
It has a cluster of only four continents,
but there's also a diagraph in this first cluster,
which makes it appear to have three continents instead of two.
So to someone looking at Polish for the first time,
it probably appears to be full of long consonant clusters,
even though some of them are just diagraphs.
Most simple Polish continents are pronounced like their English equivalents,
but note that C is pronounced as, and as I mentioned before,
w is pronounced and also note that the letters X,
V and Q are not used in Polish.
The sound AXA usually represented by X and English is spelled K S in
Polish.
One important feature of Polish pronunciation is hard and soft consonants.
A common feature of Slavic languages.
Soft consonants are generally palatalized like a hard consonant pronounced
together with a sound aside from you and LA,
which are always soft,
soft consonants are indicated by an accent above the letter or by an eye
following the continent, for example, so and HSA, no,
and near and Pia.
Most of the diagraphs we saw before belong to a subset of hard consonants that
derived from historically soft consonants.
Why do hard and soft consonants matter? Because in Polish,
some inflectional suffixes are different depending on whether they are proceeded
by a hard consonant or a soft consonant.
Most continents.
Specifically abstruse once stops Africans and fricatives.
When they appear in consonant, clusters must all be voiced or voiceless.
This results in voice stops truants becoming voiceless when they come before or
after a voiceless consonant, for example.
Fiat Orca. This also.
It happens at the ends of words, this word, meaning car, some, a hoot,
and this word, meaning doctor,
this type of devoicing is one of the main things that keeps Polish from being a
fully phonetic language. In other words,
a language in which one grapheme equals one sound.
Another thing is that the distinction between a few sounds has been lost so that
now these letters are pronounced the same.
Grammar. Let's start with the word order of Polish. The unmarked.
Or neutral word order in Polish is SVO as an English. For example.
[Inaudible] meaning.
Child is cute, or my child is sweet.
The word order here is exactly like an English subject verb compliment.
The sentence has no object, but the adjective here is a compliment.
Another example, masters, NY, albeit, which means the man is eating dinner,
subject verb object. Notice that there is no definite article in Polish.
And actually there isn't an indefinite article either.
Now this is the unmarked or neutral word order,
but Polish word order is quite flexible.
And elements of the sentence can be moved in order to emphasize them in the
first sentence, we could emphasize my child by moving it to the.
End. [inaudible].
In the second sentence, we could emphasize, man, by moving it to the.
End, I'll be out to your is now.
So the sentence is now dinner eats the man,
technically any word order as possible though,
something sound unnatural and would be most suitable for written poetry or
something.
How can these words be moved around freely like this doesn't that get confusing?
The main reason is that Polish is a highly inflected language and nouns.
Among other words have case endings endings that tell us the function of the
word in the sentence,
because the function of the word is obvious from its ending.
And we don't need to use word order or syntax to determine the function of the
word jets means child.
This is the singular form in the nominative case,
which is usually used for the subject of a sentence or a predicate adjective
after a linking verb, there are six other cases in Polish genitive,
dative, accusative,
instrumental locative invocative. These are the singular forms,
but there are also plural forms.
It's important to note that Polish has grammatical gender jets is a neuter noun
in their most basic form. The nominative form,
nutrient nouns end in F L all or, um,
there are also masculine and feminine nouns,
masculine nouns in their nominative form. Usually end in a continent.
An example is who a buck, meaning boy,
some case endings differ between different types of masculine nouns.
Compare Coopa,
a masculine person to bonk a masculine object.
Notice there's a difference in the accusative. Plural.
The endings are different for masculine people on the one hand and masculine
objects and animals on the other for many nouns.
This is also true for the nominative plural.
Also notice that the genitive and accusative singular endings are different in
these cases, the endings are different from masculine animate nouns.
In other words,
humans and animals on the one hand and inanimate objects on the other though,
in the genitive case,
a few types of nouns are acceptions feminine announced in their nominative form,
usually end in op or for example, Metallica,
meaning mother adjectives also agree with nouns in gender number and
case, and they have their own sets of endings. For example,
more than Metallica means a young mother in the nominative case,
but here's a phrase in the genitive.
Case. [inaudible].
The young mother's child. Not only the noun has a genitive case ending,
but so does the adjective and notice that the adjectives genital vending is
different from the nouns,
adjectives have endings for all cases in all genders,
for both singular and plural verbs,
Polish verbs have two tenses past and non past,
but there are also two major aspects which indicate completion of an action,
the perfective aspect, or incompletion of an action. The imperfection of aspect,
each verb has separate infinitives for the imperfection and perfective aspect.
And then conjugations are built around those infinitives in order to indicate
the tents. In other words,
the time at which the complete or incomplete action is done,
let's take a look at the verb, meaning to read, to touch.
This is an imperfection of infinitive. In other words,
the reading is in progress or ongoing shut, touch.
This is a perfective infinitive, meaning the reading is complete.
The perfective form of verbs is derived from the imperfect of form by adding a
prefix to it,
or sometimes by adding a suffix or changing a vowel in the verb STEM.
Now let's conjugate these in the past tense,
you drop the Chuck from the end of the infinitive and add one of these endings
to the remaining STEM. For example, [inaudible] means I was reading.
In other words, the reading was ongoing at a certain point in the past.
Yep. Such a thumb means. I.
Read. In other words,
I completed the action of reading within a certain time period in the past,
by the way, please note that Polish is a pro drop language,
meaning that the subject pronoun can often be left out.
And that's because the verb endings often make it clear who the subject is.
But something to note is how the verbs are conjugated for gender in the past
tense in the first and second person, singular,
there are masculine and feminine forms.
The third person singular also has a neuter form for the plural forms.
The distinction is between masculine personal endings. In other words,
for people and all the others,
a masculine inanimate object or animal will be conjugated the same as for
feminine or neutral nouns. So while a man.
Say yes to him, a woman would say Yatra tower.
And if you're talking to a man, you would say [inaudible],
but if you're talking to a woman,
you would say [inaudible] speakers of other Slavic languages.
Won't see anything strange about this,
but speakers of Germanic and romance languages might need to get used to this.
Now let's take a look at the non past conjugations, non past.
What do you mean by non past? Is it present or future? Well,
that depends on whether it's in perfective or perfective for an imperfect verb
like to touch the non past conjugation has present tense,
meaning for a perfective verb,
like such it touch the non past conjugation has future tense.
Meaning I'll not production.
This means she's reading a book while this sentence.
On that [inaudible] means.
She will read a book. Unlike the past tense conjugations,
the non past conjugations don't have any gender distinctions.
The tricky thing about the non past conjugation as that,
there isn't just one of them.
There are actually four different conjugations with virtually all verbs
following one of them conjugation one and conjugation four are characterized
by an evil in the third person,
singular form conjugation to by an owl in the third person,
singular form and conjugation three by an eight vowel in the third person,
singular the perfective non past form is sometimes referred to
as the simple future.
There's another compound future tense that expresses the imperfection of future.
In other words, an action that is ongoing or repeating in the.
Future on that Ben [inaudible].
This sentence means she will be reading a book it's formed by using the future
tense of. The word meaning to be followed by the imperfection of infinitive.
is an irregular verb using a different verb STEM in the past present and future
forms. Here's an example in the present tense.
This means I'm not Polish. And as a quick side note here,
we see how Polish negation works. You simply place the negation particle. Yeah.
Before the verb, now that we've examined some of the major features of Polish,
let's take a look at a few more sentences and see what we find this sentence
means. My father reads two books every day.
[Inaudible].
Word for word it's my father. Every day, read two books. First off,
we see a possessive adjective before the noun, meaning father possessive,
adjectives and Polish are inflected for the gender.
And number of the now hear the word. All each its meaning.
Father is masculine and singular.
So the possessive is in its masculine singular form.
And OIT jets is in the nominative case next.
So Jenya is an advert. Meaning every day, the word for day is genuine.
Next. We see the third person masculine,
singular present tense form of the verb. Next, we see the number Divya,
which means two numbers.
One to four in Polish have different forms depending on the case and gender of
the noun they are referring to Divya is feminine and is used for nominative and
accusative case here. It's the accusative.
The number is feminine because the word for book is feminine. [inaudible]
is the plural form used for nominative and accusative cases.
And here it's the accusative. A moment ago,
I mentioned that numbers one to four have different numerous forms,
numbers higher than four have only two forms when counting masculine,
personal nouns,
they are in the genitive case and the nouns they refer to are in the genitive
case. And when counting all other nouns,
they are in the nominative accusative case,
but the noun is still in the genitive case.
So if we change the number in the sentence, say from two to five,
the sentence look like this. My father reads five books every day.
[Inaudible] the number five has two forms being true for masculine people and
binge for all.
Others,
including objects like books showing this now is in the genitive plural form.
And one more sentence.
This sentence means everyone likes him because he often laughs
[inaudible] Word for word it's everyone, him.
They like because often reflexive pronoun laughs.
First we see the pronoun,
meaning everyone pronouns in Polish have different case forms.
Since this is the subject of the sentence. It's in the nominative case.
Next we see a personal pronoun,
meaning him personal pronouns also have different case forms.
This one is in the accusative case. There are two other accusative forms.
Yeah, go, yeah, go, go.
Is used.
When the pronoun is not being emphasized is the third person plural
form of the verb Lew beach,
meaning to like this verb belongs to conjugation too.
And has an I vowel in the third person singular next we see Bo a
conjunction meaning because, and after that we see Johnston an adverb,
meaning often next we see a reflexive verb,
meaning he laughs Polish has lots of reflexive verbs,
meaning that both the doer and the receiver of the action are the same.
That may not always be obvious in terms of meaning, but in terms of grammar,
that's how it works. This word share is a reflexive pronoun,
which you simply add to the verb to form the reflexive. It has only one form.
Finally, something simple in Polish. The verb here is in the third person,
singular present tense. And this for belongs to conjugation one.
Let me take this part of the sentence and ask a question about it.
Just to go to beyond meaning does everyone like him?
The way you ask yes or no questions in Polish is very simple.
You simply add the question, marker. Let's formulate another question.
This means who do they like?
[inaudible] this is an open-ended question using an interrogative pronoun,
meaning who interrogative pronouns in Polish have different case forms.
This one is in the accusative case, in the nominative case,
it takes a different form. So if you wanted to ask, who likes him, it would.
Be [inaudible].
Is the nominative form honorable mention.
This is a last minute addition to the video,
but several Polish speakers have asked me to include this particular feature of
the language. When talking about the presence of something in Polish,
you use the verb, meaning to be.
For example, on two yest means he is here.
That seems straightforward. The unusual part is the negative form.
Not it has him here. So this is like saying it doesn't have him here,
but who is it? I don't know. But I suppose it's like a dummy subject in English.
Like when we say it's sunny, it doesn't really refer to anything.
As you can see Polish an extremely interesting language,
but it's also one that many learners find daunting and intimidating.
But as with any language, there are people who learn it,
whether they move to Poland or they're simply deeply interested in Polish
culture, those people didn't learn everything about the language all at once.
They learned certain pieces first,
then they learned other pieces afterwards until eventually they had a fuller
picture of the language. So don't let the details of Polish scare you off.
If you have the interest and the motivation to go for it.
The question of the day to native speakers of Polish,
what additional features of Polish would you like to tell us about, for example,
are there any features of informal speech that you would like to share and to
students of Polish? What do you find most challenging about the language?
Do you have any tips on how to deal with it? If you enjoyed this video,
then please check out the various Lang focus, social media accounts.
And of course, as always,
I want to give a very special thanks to my Patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the screen,
who are my top tier Patrion supporters.
So I want to say a very special thanks to them for their support and to
everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.